[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
hello everyone and welcome to a another
ilp first look video uh
my name is lord petey uh i'm here to
give you all a little bit of an
introduction and a little uh little
sneak peek into uh what uh this game is
this game is dwarf romantic now um this
game is a
very much a
chill relaxing
fun
uh fun game so um
as you can see right now it's probably a
little interesting for you to see it i'm
actually playing this offline i wanted
to play it offline because
i wanted to enjoy uh enjoy playing it i
wanted to kind of see what was going on
i was having a very very bad day
um
with everything going on at home but i
wanted to make sure that i took a little
bit of time
and uh and played this game and this
game actually helped me relax and very
much let me chill now the whole
objective of the game is to get higher
scores
uh by placing different tiles next to
each other now the interesting part
about the tiles are that each tile is
different
and each tile on the side could be
something totally different it could be
a plane it could be a
field it could be a water it could be a
train track it could be
many different things houses of trees i
can't even tell you how many different
things because there is so many
different things to go through
um but one of the things i will say is
that
dwarf romantic
is a very beautiful
very very much low-key
game and i love it um
it was
it was one of those things where
i wanted to kind of
sit and relax and i wanted to kind of
see what this game might have to offer
and
this game definitely did not um
it didn't it
it didn't kind of uh it didn't stop me
from wanting to play it even more
um so
uh
i wanted to kind of like see and play
with it and
i really enjoy it i like it
and
i mean there's nothing there's nothing
really much to say if you just kind of
wanted this game to kind of just want to
watch something to kind of chill
what you end up doing is you take your
tiles you kind of spin them around
uh you you place them next to each other
and form um different types of
communities
uh the possibilities are endless um
the
thing that you want to make sure you do
is you want to make sure you place like
tiles next to each other to allow them
to grow
to produce certain um criteria now
you'll start to see houses like start to
see little pictures popping up on some
of the tiles that'll be like a river
tile that'll have like a river on it and
i'll say like five meaning you need to
put five river tiles next to each other
or a house that that'll say you know
like a house with like 20 plus on it
meaning you want 20 houses to be next to
each other
or you might see something that says
like
that's a house and it would be like
house 10 meaning they only want 10
houses
exactly to produce this community and
you kind of just start building out and
building out and building out and
the more
the more of those achievements you
complete the more you end up getting as
uh more tiles back which allow you to
play longer
and
i mean i can't say much other than it's
just a beautiful relaxing chill game
that you know if you want to kind of
just sit back chill
have a nice little time
this game is really well um once you
start completing more and more
tile objectives the more and more
uh newer tiles you'll get for instance
um you know we unlocked a bunch while we
were playing
the riverboat we unlocked the train we
unlocked um
lavender fields i mean it's just
uh there's
what else am i gonna say the game is
just
a beautiful relaxing fun game
that you know
it takes your mind to use to be able to
produce
these villages and towns and there's so
many different um
you know there's there's so many
different types of
tiles and different uh player modes you
have a creator player mode so you don't
have to worry about points and
i
if you are looking to you know to play a
game like this check them out um if you
know you're waiting to end up
waiting for it to go on sale you know by
all means you could do that too
but it is just it's really good um
so i just once again i wanted to kind of
just sit here and tell you what was
going on
show you a little bit of the enjoyment
of uh dwarf romantic
and uh you know if you're looking for me
personally this is uh you know lord pdtv
um
i am on twitch every monday through
friday from from 3 p.m to 11 p.m uh we
play multiple different games there we
play you know some of the even these
games that we're discussing here and uh
we end up playing some warcraft we end
up playing some you know
different types of stuff we end up
playing some deep rock galactic
sometimes you know some view rising you
know it all depends um but make sure you
come check us out uh i greatly think
that you will all appreciate it all
right thank you all and uh have a
fantastic rest of your your weekend if
you're looking to check out uh anybody
this weekend uh remember to check out
the uh iron lords podcast on sundays and
check uh lordsygaming.net for any of
your gaming news um this is uh lord pdtv
again saying thank you and have a
fantastic day all right dream big keep
gaming see you later bye everybody
so
so
bye
hmm
[Music]
you